[Music]
hey everyone it's me
your BFF Debbie welcome 2017 [ __ ] I'm
here to help you walk off your holiday
hangover and help you come to terms with
the fact that sugar it's ruining your
night
whoa they're a drama queen you're being
a bit hasty sugar is the root cause of
cancer obesity diabetes heart disease
tooth decay anymore Deb it's also linked
to global warming and your mother's
perpetual distaste for faster the bottom
line is sugar is evil and I'm gonna help
you get it out of your life for good
[Music]
and I'm gonna tell you why you shouldn't
don't listen to her you don't see her
rockin with wands you like a champ
do ya no no you don't and you won't
exactly so first of all a little
tutorial on how to spot sugars in quinoa
soy whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
before you go cutting out any and all
carbs let's differentiate sugar from all
the other kinds of carbs and actually
you can just look at the type of sugar
that even matters so sure's basically
just a type of carb along with starches
and fiber and there are different types
of carbohydrate depending on how many
sugar molecules there are one or two
sugar molecules are considered sugars
and more than two bound together are
considered starches or fibers so aside
from fibers which don't break down the
same way all carbohydrates are broken
down in our bodies to yield the most
usable form for us which is essentially
like a simple sugar like glucose and yes
you can find sugars added to cupcakes
and cocktails but you can also find
naturally occurring sugars in foods like
dairy and fruit but we're actually not
concerned with these kinds of natural
sugars what we're concerned about is
what we call free sugars which are
sugars that have been removed from their
natural source and are devoid of any
kind of fiber or protein to help slow
down their absorption so the World
Health Organization actually recommends
that you try to limit your free sugars
to about 10% of your daily energy intake
so that means really keeping tabs on
foods like white sugar brown sugar honey
maple syrup agave and even fruit juice
was cleansing no Debbie just no and if
you're thinking about cutting back on
sugars this should be like the first
thing to go
fruit juice is considered a free sugar
because those sugars are isolated
without any of the beneficial fibers it
helps slow down their absorption but
whole fruits on the other hand are
totally a ok because they have that
beneficial built in fiber help avoid any
blood sugar spice gosh that's confusing
I think you just cut out all the carbs
we can avoid those pesky sugars No
Debbie and here's why number one fiber
carbs and yes even natural sugar
containing foods contain beneficial
fibers which were really important for
promoting regularity maintaining and
managing your weight and controlling
blood sugar and cholesterol so women
should aim for about 25 grams a day and
Men for about 38 grams a day from foods
that yes
contain carbs number two your brain your
brain actually needs about 130 grams of
sugar each day to function optimally I
mean remember that time that aunt Joe
went on that really low carb Atkins diet
and she literally could not form a
sentence yeah she was a little deprived
and judging by your logic Debbie I would
say you're a little under fed to number
3 activity ask some of the most elite
athletes out there if they cut out sugar
in carbs and they're probably gonna
laugh in your face even some simple
sugars can become imperative for certain
free and post workouts so if you're
being active definitely don't make this
mistake there are a lot of carbohydrate
and natural sugar containing foods that
are loaded with minerals nutrients and
antioxidants and adopting a really low
carb diet can be both dangerous and
unpleasant
I mean you are being a little bit hasty
there today Doug what are you talking
about you for being up here
okay let's get back to my list number
four disordered eating new research
suggests that cutting out certain food
groups or going like a really
restrictive diets can lead to a whole
host of different disordered eating
patterns including the newly popularized
disorder orthorexia and finally social
life when you adopt such a strict diet
dining out with friends and family can
become next to impossible I mean sure we
know that there are carbs and sugar in
wine and cocktails and dessert but there
are also lots of carbs and sugar
lingering and seemingly savory foods as
well
tons of dips and dressings marinades and
sauces are loaded with sugar and I'm not
telling you this to scare you daddy I'm
just trying to give you a bit of a
reality check oh yeah that does say the
bottom line is I never recommend someone
start a diet unless they think that they
can continue that diet for the long run
and this is one of those diets that I
would not want to be doing for long
I rest my case
so do you or one of your friends have a
specific food or food group that you're
thinking about totally cutting out well
leave me a comment below and I'll do a
deep dive to uncover whether or not
that's a good idea for you also if you
liked this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music]